i think it's interesting to talk about
a little bit of the human story of the
nobel prize sure which is
i mean it's fascinating it's a really s
first of all the prize itself
it's kind of fascinating in the
psychological level that uh
prizes uh i know we kind of think that
prizes don't matter but somehow they
kind of focus the mind about
some of the most special things we will
do push the recognition the funding
you know but and also inspiration for
you
like i said when i was a little kid
thinking about the nobel prize like i
didn't you know
it inspires millions of young scientists
at the same time there's a sadness to it
a little bit
that uh especially in the field like
depending on the field but
experimental fields that involve teams
of i don't know
sometimes hundreds i mean yeah of
brilliant people
the nobel prize is only given to just a
handful i
that's right is it max at three yeah
yeah and it's not even written in alfred
nobel's will it turns out one of our
teammates looked into it
in a museum in stockholm when we went
there for nobel week in 2011.
the the leaders who got the prize
formally knew that without the rest of
us working hard in the trenches
the result would not have you know been
discovered
so they invited us to participate in
nobel week and so one of the
team members looked in the will and it's
not there it's just tradition
that's something but it's archaic you
know that's the way science used to be
done
yeah it's not the way a lot of science
is done now and you look at
gravitational wave discovery which was
you know recognized with the nobel prize
in 2017
ray weiss at mit got it and kip thorne
and um and um barry barish at caltech
and ron drever one of the masterminds
had passed away
earlier in the year so again one of the
rules of the nobel is that it's not
given posthumously
yeah or at least the one exception might
be if they've made their decision and
they're
busy making their press releases right
before october
the first week in october or whatever
and then the person passes away i think
they don't change their minds then but
yeah you know it it it doesn't
square with today's reality that a lot
of science is done by
big teams in that case a team of a
thousand people in our case it was two
teams
consisting of about 50 people and we
used
techniques that were arguably developed
in part by people who
astrophysicists who weren't even on
those two papers i mean some of them
were but
other papers were written by by other
people you know and so
it's like we're standing on the
shoulders of giants and none of those
people
was officially recognized and to me
it was okay you know again it was the
thrill of doing the work
and ultimately the work the discovery
was recognized with the prize
and you know we got to participate in
nobel week and
you know it's okay with me i i've known
other physicists whose lives were ruined
because
they did not get the nobel prize and
they felt
strongly that they should have so ralph
alpher
of the alpha beta gamma you know paper
predicting the microwave background
radiation
he should have gotten it his advisor
gamoff was dead by that
point but um you know penzias and wilson
got it for the discovery and
and alpha apparently from colleagues who
knew him well i've talked to them
his life was ruined by this he just it
just nod at his
innards so much it's uh very possible
that
uh in a small handful of people even
three that you would be one of the noble
the one of the winners of the nobel
prize that doesn't weigh heavy on you
well you know there were the two team
leaders saul pearl mudder and brian
schmidt and usually there's the team
leaders that are recognized and then
adam reese was my postdoc first he was
first author i guess yeah first author i
was second author of that paper yeah
uh so i was his direct mentor at the
time although he was you know one of
these people who just
you know runs with things he was an mit
undergraduate by the way
um harvard graduate student and then a
postdoc as a so-called miller fellow
for basic research in science at
berkeley something that i was back in 84
to 86
but you're you're you know you're
largely a free agent but he worked quite
closely with me and he came to berkeley
to work with me and
on schmidt's team he was charged with
analyzing the data
and he measured the brightnesses of
these distant supernovae
showing that they're fainter and thus
more distant than anticipated and that
led to this
conclusion that the universe had to have
accelerated in order to
push them out to such great distances
and i was shocked
when he showed me the data the results
of his calculations and measurements
um but it's very you know so he deserved
it but and on saul's
girls and gerson goldhaber deserved it
but he died i think a year earlier in
but that would have been four and so
and me well i was on both teams but you
know was i number four
five six seven i don't know well it's
also very
so if i were to it's possible that
you're
i mean i could make a very good case for
you're in in the three
and the does that say you're kind you
know
so is that psychologically i mean listen
it weighs on me a little bit because i
yeah i i don't know what to do with that
it it uh perhaps it should motivate
uh the rethinking like time magazine
started doing like you know person of
the year yeah and like they would
they would start doing like concepts and
almost like the black
hole gets the nobel prize or yeah or i
think
universe gets the nobel prize and here's
the list of people
so like ult or like the oscar that you
could
say yeah because it it's a team effort
now it's a team
oh and it should be redone and the
breakthrough prize in fundamental
physics which was started by yuri milner
and zuckerberg is involved in others as
well you know
uh they remember the larger team yeah
they they
recognize teams and so in fact both
teams in the accelerating universe
were recognized with the breakthrough
prize in 2015
nevertheless the same three people
reese perlmutter and schmidt got the red
carpet rolled out for them
and were at the big ceremony and shared
half of the prize money
and the rest of us roughly 50 shared the
other half and didn't get to go to the
ceremony
so but i i feel for them i mean for the
gravitational waves it was a thousand
people what are they gonna do
invite everyone yeah for the higgs
particle it was six to eight thousand
physicists and engineers
in fact because of the whole issue of
who gets it
experimentally that discovery still has
not been recognized
right the theoretical work by peter
higgs
and uh anglair got recognized but
there was a troika of other people who
writ perhaps wrote the most complete
paper and they were
they were left out and um another guy
died you know and it's hard it's all of
his heartbreaking some people argue that
the
nobel prize has been deluded to because
if you look at roger penrose
you can make an argument that he should
get the prize by himself
like she'll separate those like could
have and should have perhaps he should
have perhaps gotten it with hawking
before hawking's death yeah right the
problem was
hawking radiation had not been detected
but you could argue that hawking made
enough other
fundamental contributions to the
theoretical study of black holes and
the observed data were already good
enough
at the time of before hawking's death
okay i mean the latest results by
reinhard genzel's group is that they see
the time dilation effect of a star
that's passing very close to the
black hole in the middle of our galaxy
that's cool but and it adds additional
evidence but hardly anyone
doubted the existence of the
supermassive black hole and andrea
ghaz's group
i believe hadn't yet shown that
relativistic effect and yet she got part
of the prize as well so clearly
it was given for the the original
evidence that was really good and that
evidence is at least a decade old you
know so one could make the case
for for hawking um one could make the
case that
in 2016 when mayor and kaylos
won the nobel prize for the discovery of
the first exoplanet
51 b pegasi well there was a fellow at
penn state
alex wolshan who in 1992
three years preceding 1995 found a
pel a planet orbiting a pulsar a very
weird kind of star a neutron star and
that
wouldn't have been a normal planet sure
and so the nobel committee you know
they gave it for the discovery of
planets around normal
sun-like stars but but hell you know
wolshan found a
planet so they could have given it to
him as the third person
instead of to jim peebles for the
development of what's called physical
cosmology
he's at princeton he deserved it but
they could have given
nobel for the development of physical
cosmology
to peebles and i would claim some other
people were pretty important in that
development as well you know and
they could have given it some other year
um so
there's there's a lot of controversy i
try not to dwell on it was i number
three probably not you know
adam reese did the work um you know i
helped
bounce ideas off of him but we wouldn't
have had the result without him
yeah and i was on both teams for
reasons i mean you know i the the style
of the first team the supernova
cosmology project didn't match mine
they came largely from experimental high
energy particle physics
physics where there's these hierarchical
teams and stuff and it's hard for
the little guy to to have a say at least
that's what i kind of thought
whereas the team of astronomers led by
brian schmidt
was first of all a bunch of my friends
and they grew up as
astronomers making contributions on
little teams and we decided to band
together but all of us had our voices
heard
so it was sort of a a culture a style
that i preferred
really but let me tell you a story at
the nobel banquet okay
i'm sitting there between two physicists
who are who are members of the committee
of the swedish national academy of
sciences
you know and i strategically kept you
know offering them wine and stuff during
this long
drawn out nobel ceremony yeah right
and i got them to be pretty talkative
and then in a in a polite diplomatic way
i started asking them pointed questions
and basically they admitted that if
there are four or more people
equally deserving they wait for one of
them to die
or they just don't give the prize at all
when it's unclear
who the three are at least unclear to
them but
unclear to them it's they're not even
right
part of the time i mean jocelyn bell
discovered pulsars
with a radio antenna a set of radio
antennas that
her advisor anthony hewish
conceived and built so he deserves some
credit
but but he didn't discover the pulsar
she did
and his initial reaction to the
data that she showed him was a
condescending
rubbish my dear yeah i'm not kidding no
i know she did not let this destroy her
life
yeah she won every other prize under the
sun
okay um vera rubin
arguably one of the discoverers of dark
matter although there
if you look at the history there were a
number of people that was the issue i
think there were a number of people four
or more
who had similar data and similar ideas
at about the same time
reuben won every prize under the sun the
new big
large-scale survey telescope being built
in chile is being renamed
the vera rubin telescope because she
passed away in december of 2015 i think
um you know it'll conduct
this survey large scale survey with the
reuben telescope so
she's been recognized but never with the
nobel prize and
i would say that to her credit she did
not let that
consume her life either and perhaps it
was a bit easier because there had been
no
nobel given for the discovery of dark
matter whereas in the case of pulsars
and jocelyn bell
there was a prize given for the
discovery of the freaking pulsars
and she didn't get it what i mean what a
travesty of justice
so i i also think
as a fan of fiction as a fan of stories
that the
the travesty and the tragedy and the
unfairness
and the tension of it is what makes the
prize
and similar prizes beautiful the
the decisions of other humans that
result
in dreams being broken and
on you know like that's why we love the
olympics
as so many you know people athletes give
their whole life
for this particular moment and then and
then there's referee decisions
and like little slips of here and there
like the little misfortunes
that destroy entire dreams and that's
it's weird to say but it feels like that
makes the entirety of it even more
special
yeah if it was perfect it wouldn't be
interesting well humans like competition
and they like
heroes and yeah unfortunately it gives
the impression to youngsters today that
science is still done by by white men
with gray beards
wearing white lab coats and i'm very
pleased
to see that this year you know andrea
guezz the fourth woman
in the history of the physics prize to
have received it
and then uh two women one at berkeley
one elsewhere won the nobel prize in
chemistry without any
male co-recipient and so that's sending
a message i think to girls
that they can do science and they have
um
role models i think the breakthrough
prize and other such
prizes show that teams get recognized as
well
and and if you pay attention to the
newspapers
you know most of the good authors like
you know dennis overby of the new york
times and others
said that these were teams of people and
they they emphasized that and
you know they all played a role um and
you know maybe if some grad student
hadn't soldered some
circuit maybe the whole thing wouldn't
have worked you know um
but still you know ray weiss
kip thorne was the theoretical uh
you know impetus for the whole search
for gravitational waves
barry barish brought the mit and caltech
teams together
to get them to cooperate at a time when
the project was nearly dead from what i
understand
and contributed greatly to the
experimental setup as well he's a great
experimental physicist but he was really
good
at bringing these two teams together
instead of having them duke it out and
blows and leaving both of them bleeding
and dying
you know that national science
foundation was going to cut the funding
from what i understand
you know so so there's human drama
involved in this whole thing and the
olympics yeah you know
a runner a swimmer a rummer runner you
know they they slip
just at the moment that they were taking
off from the first thing and that costs
them some fraction of a second
and that's it they didn't win you know
and in that case i mean the the coaches
the families
which i met a lot of olympic athletes
and the coaches and the families of the
athletes
are really the winners of the medals
yeah i mean it's but they don't get the
medal i
in excel it's you know credited
assignment is a fascinating thing i mean
that's the full human story we have oh
yeah we have in and uh outside of prizes
it's fascinating i mean uh just to be in
the middle of it for artificial
intelligence there's a field
of deep learning that's really exciting
and people have been there's a
yet another award uh the touring awards
sure
given for deep learning to to three
folks
who are very much responsible for the
field but so are a lot of others
yeah that's right and there's a few
there's uh uh there's
a a fellow by the name of schmidt huber
who uh
so he sort of symbolizes the
the forgotten folks in the deep learning
community
but it you know that's that's the
unfortunate sad thing we remember
remembering isaac newton i remember uh
these
these these special figures and the ones
that
flew close to them uh we forget
well that's right and you know often the
breakthroughs were made based on the
body of knowledge that
had been assimilated prior to that
but you know again people like to
worship heroes you mentioned the oscars
earlier and
you know you look at the direct i mean
well i mean
okay directors and stuff sometimes get
awards and stuff but
you know you look at even something like
i don't know songwriters musicians elton
john or something right bernie taupin
right
wrote many of the words or
he's not as well known or or the beatles
or something like that i was heartbroken
to learn that elvis didn't write most of
his songs
yeah elvis that's right they're very
excited but he was the king
right yeah and he had such a personality
and he was such a performer
right but it's the unsung heroes in many
cases yeah
you